at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking no question I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton hello hello this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show this is a
special edition it is brought to you
sponsor free and I would like to ask a
favor in exchange but we're gonna get to
that in a second the first thing is a
description of this episode this episode
is actually a presentation by yours
truly that I wanted to share because I
get asked all the time how did you build
your network and if you look at the say
guest list from this podcast or people
that I invest alongside it seems like a
very impressive list and I'm impressed
by a lot of these people but it was
built in a very strategic a very
methodical way and that doesn't mean it
has to be artificial I'm not looking at
these friends as transactions these are
relationships that I value but there is
a right and a wrong way to network and
in fact I think the best way to build a
world-class network is to spend very
little time networking per say
collecting business cards and whatnot so
this presentation really encapsulates my
approach and what I've done particularly
since about 2007 and I gave this
presentation at South by Southwest which
is a huge conference it started off with
music then the interactive technology
portion exploded and don't worry about
the slides the visuals in each case if I
bring up a slide I explain it via voice
so you really don't need the visuals I
was able to experience a tipping point
for the 4-hour workweek when I gave my
first presentation at South by Southwest
and I won't go into all the story
because I'd do it in the presentation
but it really triggered everything that
came after it so it was a game changer a
life changer for me so what did i do
exactly at South by Southwest that
helped it become yet quote the most
surprising self-help hit of the decade
and
according to Men's Journal how did that
happen and in the session I talk about
exactly what I did that led to a higher
likelihood of that type of Black Swan
event in the positive so I talked about
bio hacks for surviving and optimizing
the booze marathon or sleep deprivation
which is inherent to events like this
whether it's South by Southwest Ted any
number of other events that are
multi-day this is an important point and
a very important subject to master the
top mistakes that I think 90% of
attendees make how to pick your sessions
parties etc to make the most of all the
madness how to interact with a listers
or not and this is a very very important
subject that I delve into and how to set
yourself apart enjoy the ride and come
away from the whole thing smiling
because it is it is my opinion that if
you choose one event properly and you
build a network there in the right way
in a methodical way that really focuses
on sort of long term mutual
relationships as opposed to transactions
and a lot of the advice I think is
counterintuitive or non-obvious but it's
very specific that you never have to
network again ever
and once you set that ball in motion
it's like a snowball going down a hill
and before you know it you have this
unstoppable Goliath of inertia that can
carry you forward for years and in fact
decades and that is what happened for me
at South by Southwest in 2007 and I want
to explain exactly how that happened
which is what this session will go into
and the favor that I would love to ask
you guys is I would love to try to
minimize sponsorships if possible
because I only take sponsorships from
companies whose products I use and have
vetted and so on at the very least so I
don't want to take a lot of sponsors I
want to really limit it to that subset
but the way that I can do that is by
having you do something like subscribe
to my newsletter so for instance five
bullet Friday's if you haven't been
receiving these every Friday I sent out
a very short email of five bullets
containing the coolest things that I
have found or been playing with that
week which could include favorite
articles that I've shared with friends
it could include gizmos and gadgets that
I've
dug up somehow through experts and
purchased and played with all sorts of
randomness but a lot of awesome stuff
that you can use immediately and it's a
very very short
hence five bullet email so to check that
out it's free and you can sign up very
easily try it out for a week so you
think at a four hour workweek comm
forward slash fridays all spelled out
four hour workweek comm forward slash
fridays so if you would like me to cut
back on sponsors then please go sign up
it would mean a lot to me and I think
you will love it if you go on Twitter
and just look at hashtag five the number
five five bullet Fridays you will see a
lot of people are excited about this
that is it so without further ado or
volume peeking I hope you enjoy this
presentation on exactly how I built my
network which is one of the most common
questions that I get so enjoy it
please let me know your feedback I am at
t Ferris TF e RR ISS on Twitter and
thank you for listening
hey guys I'm flanked by dignitaries I
used to have a rat tail how did I get
invited to this party
well thank you all for coming I feel a
huge debt of gratitude to South by
Southwest because in 2007 prior to that
the 4-hour workweek had been turned down
by 26 publishers violently in many cases
and then at South by that year was the
tipping point for the 4-hour workweek
went on to hit the New York Times stayed
there for almost four years unbroken
millions of copies 30 plus languages
later Here I am presenting kind of crazy
and I've been back basically every year
since so I feel like I have a playbook a
couple of tips tactics that hopefully
you can use over the next few days to
get the most out of this event because I
really feel like if you do South by
properly once you never have to network
ever again you don't have to schmooze
you can just coast and ride it out so
I'll try to give you quite a bit of
actionable information the subject
matter of the previous presenter and the
one after me far more important but I
guarantee probably more profanity and
crassness in this one so this particular
slide is me at Burning Man 2008 after
being thrilled with what happened at
South by I have very little recollection
of this particular instance and I
suspect that may be true for many of you
over the next few days so let's start
with avocados no not avocados we're
going to talk about booze and
specifically how you can mitigate the
damage that you're going to inflict on
yourselves over the next few days and
I'm not going to necessarily stop you
from getting drunk I think that's part
of the fun of being here I'm not gonna
stop you from getting dragged out of a
club yelling Do You Know Who I am you
can do that too but I want to help
minimize the hangovers and the missing
of sessions the missing of days here
because that's a real travesty so a
couple of recommendations if you've ever
time traveled on alcohol what I mean by
that is you're at a club then suddenly
you're at Denny's eating moons over my
hammy you're like how do I get here
you've experienced a lack of vasopressin
vasopressin is
a hormone that is associated with
short-term memory and ethanol the booze
inhibits its release all right so you
can compensate for that by let's say
inhaling desmopressin which is a
synthetic version don't do that I don't
recommend that but you can I'll retain
more water why is this key because it's
also an antidiuretic hormone the reason
you piss like a racehorse is also
related to this vasopressin and the
reason you feel so hungover is because
you've been dehydrated for a long period
of time so a very easy way to get around
this especially in Austin is to have a
bunch of guacamole before you go out
have some avocados has more potassium
than bananas also a bunch of things that
counter inflammation ok so super simple
put a bunch of salt on it if you want to
be indulgent you can put some balsamic
vinegar in the middle as well which will
lower your glycemic response to the
pizza that you have five pieces of when
you're drunk later it actually has a
tremendous effect have one glass of
water for every alcoholic beverage you
have another way that you can mitigate
the damage is to have clean drinks what
would be an example of a clean drink
well if you want to get as drunk as
possible with the least amount of effort
and the least hangover you could have
something called a NorCal margarita a
NorCal margarita popularized by a guy
named Rob wolf in the paleo community is
quite simply say two shots of high-grade
tequila Reposado is a good choice mixed
with a bunch of club soda and as much
lime as you can tolerate lemon will also
work just it doesn't taste quite as good
the club soda will allow you to absorb
it very very quickly so you can be a
cheap date and the the lime will also
just like the vinegar and hit that your
glycemic response to food later so if
you end up binging you won't have a car
of an insulin coma the next day all
right the last tip related to booze
because I think this is such a key key
subject to master while you're here is
activated charcoal or carbon so if you
want to again minimize some of the
damage you could go try to find that
probably late for a lot of you to try to
do that burnt toast okay eat some burnt
toast before you go out that doesn't
sound appealing you can scrape off the
burnt bits into yogurt and eat that
which has actually been done in studies
looking at trying to
alleviate overdose of acetaminophen so
it can work surprisingly enough burnt
toast
avocados NorCal margarita there you go
all right who is this person
why is she very very important so this
woman
lovely lovely woman his name Miriam and
I met Miriam when I went to CES for the
first time the Consumer Electronics Show
I'd never made it to the tradeshow and
this is highly relevant to South by
Southwest I instead went to a sponsored
lounge was the Seagate blog house H aus
and it was where they gave bloggers at
the time that was social media basically
gave bloggers free booze power outlets a
place to rest and do work and I just
went there and I hung out all day for
several days and I had a laptop so I was
able to do work and I struck up casual
conversations with people hey what's the
most interesting session you've seen so
far any cool products he bumped into
didn't pitch anyone I got to spend time
with Miriam because she was checking
people in and we just very casually had
got into long conversations about where
we were from etc now the the big dog at
the time and he's still very influential
is Robert Scoble so he was in the blog
house everyone was crowded around him
dozens of people vying for his attention
and I knew I didn't stand a chance
I didn't have a honed pitch for him I
didn't even try and that's generally
what I recommend now it turned out that
Miriam is Robert's wife and oh yeah you
should totally hang out with Robert like
here just like shoot me shoot me a text
or send me an email and we'll just meet
up when you're back in the Bay Area
fantastic and so Robert ends up getting
a copy of the book he sends out a short
mention in a blog post it takes the book
to top 10 on Amazon for several days
compared to morning television at the
time which would only take it's a top 50
for several hours that all came about
because I followed these rules don't
dismiss people don't be a dick and don't
rush those are the three core tenets of
success at an event like South by
Southwest don't dismiss people you
should behave here like everyone you
interact with has the potential I can't
wait to see the drawings
everyone has the potential to get you a
cover story in the New York Times
because many of them do and it's just a
good way to behave all right but you
should behave like everyone here has the
potential to get you a cover story at
the New York Times
don't be dick pretty self-explanatory
but let me give a couple of examples of
all three so don't dismiss people I
already gave you one I'll give you
another one specific to South by
Southwest I was going to a few movie
screenings I went to one called big rig
pretty cool movie and I was standing in
line and the guy in front of me older
gentleman had huge forearms and this is
the kind of thing I noticed and I was
like dude what is up with the forearms
and we started talking
turns out he's a rock climber we talked
we talked we talked about nothing
business-related whatsoever turned out
to be Morgan Spurlock's brother Morgan
Spurlock showed up maybe 10 minutes
later we sat in right next to each other
at the movie and then a few years later
I ended up collaborating with him and he
profiled me for a day in the life okay
so again treat everyone like they're
important because they are don't dismiss
people I'll give you the converse
example last year I was here with my
girlfriend at the time and had dozens of
people basically facepalm my girlfriend
to push her out of the way to try to
talk to me not good politics don't be a
dick again pretty explanatory of self
explanatory not limited to men by the
way I've seen a couple of instances
where for instance a friend was speaking
to a female attendee and she asked if
she could see the apps on his home
screen and he did this she grabbed the
phone turned around and then sent a text
to her number from his phone so she
would have his phone number don't do
that don't rush this is the most
important because it turns otherwise
good reasonable wonderful people into
those who do the the aforementioned to
don't rush play the long game alright
and the mission that I would like to
offer to all of you the job should you
accept it is to realize that at South by
Southwest there are hundreds of people
who could change your life completely
who could satisfy all of your wildest
dreams financially
reputationally phantasmagorical II I
have no idea they they can really make
magic happen for you and your job should
be to try to have a deep human
connection with one of those people
before you leave that's it it makes
south-by-southwest
very very manageable an example of
rushing and this has happened to be
perhaps half a dozen times here at South
buying is the urinal encounter what is
the urinal encounter it's one I'm trying
to have my moment of Zen I'm out of
urinal and I'm like hot deep breath deep
breath you know thinking of the penguin
in the cave chilling out I'm like okay
getting ready to go back into the melee
and some startup founder will come
running up to me and skid to a stop
who's like sweating because he's nervous
and starts like panting on the back of
my neck giving me a pitch if you want to
make any human male that I'm aware of
really uncomfortable wait until they're
staring at a wall holding their penis
and come up and breathe on the back of
the neck don't rush it makes good people
do bad things I promised a crass alright
next read BIOS not sessions so how do
you choose among all of the sessions you
probably have some big fat book then
you're like oh my god how am I possibly
going to tackle any of this number one
read the BIOS not the sessions the
session titles may not tell you the
whole story look for interesting people
not titles of sessions and secondly
don't just look at the people on the
panel look at the moderators and so what
I did my first time to South by
Southwest is I would go to a panel I
would listen to these amazing people on
the pit on a given panel and then I
would go up not to the a-listers on the
panel afterwards I would go up to the
moderator many of whom are equally
impressive in their own right I would go
up to the moderator who's usually not
nearly as mobbed and I would give them a
quick explanation that say hey this is
my first time at South by I don't know
anyone kind of lost just finished my
first book it's about a B and C
personally I'm interested in at the time
say Brazilian Jujitsu this this and this
is there anyone here you think I might
really hit it off with anyone you think
I should talk to I'm pretty good at this
and this and they been yeah yeah I think
I should talk to this person in this
person and I just repeated
that line of questioning over and over
and over again and that's how I met many
of the people who led to the tipping
point for the book and when I went up to
those people who were referred by the
way I don't say so-and-so said we should
really meet don't don't oversell it just
say I went up to them I asked them this
they said this I figured what the hell
maybe we'd hit it off can I buy you a
drink
it's a very methodical way to go about
tackling this deluge of sessions next
one don't make an impression leave a
momento and I did a lot of research
online pinged my audience on Facebook
Twitter asked for questions one of them
was how do I make a positive first
impression your job at South by
Southwest is to not make a bad
impression all right because if all
you're doing is trying to sell someone
there are many different ways to do it
aside from coming to South by Southwest
what I would recommend especially in an
instance where you're trying to reach
say an a-lister right somebody who's
getting mobbed and pitched all day long
like an Anthony Bourdain or whoever it
might be don't try to give the pitch in
person give them a folded up piece of
paper with a page that you've
painstakingly crafted that is the
perfect pitch include your phone number
you'd be surprised how many VIP folks
like to call folks via Skype to have a
conversation as supposed to send you
their personal email for instance don't
make an impression leave a momento
just say hey I realize you're super busy
you got this long line of people you're
under a lot of pressure I've thought
about this I think this would be of
great interest to you and just give them
a teaser right like if you have an
impressive number a stat a client who's
using it something like that here you go
I hope you have a great South by read it
when you're on the toilet or have an
extra five minutes on the plane
thanks so much and you leave it at that
and that also shows you that you know
how to play the game you know how busy
they are you know the stress that
they're dealing with and immediately
that'll separate you from everyone else
as opposed to getting up and just
micromachining through a pitch they
won't remember even if they've
spectacular memory ignorance is bliss be
the idiot I don't have to try very hard
for this one so the key here and this is
mostly a problem with men in my
experience or boys or guys in
between is we try to impress people so
we stroll up and were like well that's a
good point you know it's even better
point or someone says something you're
like you know what that reminds me of
this story that one ups your story don't
do that and in fact you should do the
opposite so one of the experiences that
I had and challenges that many of you
will have is how do you get into a group
conversation how do you interrupt people
so my rules for that are number one if
it's two people who are deep in
conversation
don't interrupt okay remember don't rush
play the long game if it's two people
just don't interrupt wait if it's more
people three four etc you can saunter up
and do what I did in 2007 which was say
hey guys do you mind if I join you
just eavesdrop it's my first time here I
don't know anybody I'll buy you guys
around the drinks it's usually place
where you can get free drinks so it
works out really easily and they're like
okay sure
now the reason you don't just walk up
and say like hey guys I'm just gonna
eavesdrop is even though they're never
gonna say no at least you asked be
polite all right so then they'd be like
oh whatever man
so I'd hang out and typically there'd be
a lot of engineers I'm not a coder not
an engineer and if someone said
something that I was genuinely
interested in clarifying so they'd be
like well we did that and of course we
ended up with Ruby on Rails and I'd say
you know I'm really sorry I didn't drop
but deep in the ignorance pool here why
was Ruby on Rails the obvious choice I
don't know what it is but why was it
such an obvious advantage and that will
oftentimes spark it to make a debate
among the people in that group and so
every once in a while you throw out one
of these questions again being the idiot
which is what good NPR hosts also do by
the way and eventually someone will say
oh wait who the hell are you again like
what's your story and then you give them
the shortest answer possible do not
launch into a really rushed long-ass
pitch so I would say well you know it's
it's my first time here and I just
finished my first book and the publisher
is basically controlling everything
except for digital so I'm here to try to
figure it out pause then you wait to see
who asks if they do what's it about
great then you say well it's about this
this and this but I think most people
here probably this interesting and you
see who digs deeper
you'll see the logic to this in a second
so let's just say you have a group of
six people there's one person who's
expressed extreme interest by digging
and digging in the case of the 4-hour
workweek maybe they're interested in
world travel Virtual Assistants that
kind of thing
then at the very end you know we bounce
around talk about all sorts of subjects
and that's a you know zero pressure I
would never expect you to write about it
or do anything like that
but I have a bunch of promotional copies
from the publisher I get very easily
just tab the 15 to 20 pages that I think
you would find most interesting based on
what we just talked about and I can mail
it to you and you know you can use it as
a doorstop if you want and because I'd
already honed down to the point where I
knew who was interested I would say
probably 90% of those folks said yes
we're enthusiastic about it and then at
least half of them ended up promoting it
in some way because they loved it not
because I asked them to do it does that
make sense and if you say no strings
attached do not [ __ ] follow up and
bug the [ __ ] out it's a great way to get
a huge amount of negative backlash don't
do it and we'll come back to that but I
tend to do very little follow-up except
for something people have asked for
because people get enough email as it is
don't be a traffic bigot what does this
mean this means that you maybe if you
have something to promote if you have a
service website startup book album
whatever it might be movie you might be
tempted to go straight for the person
who has the biggest megaphone the
biggest site the most Twitter followers
and the the problem with that is that
you're going to be one of a thousand
people who pitch this person while
they're here it 99.9 percent of the time
it won't work you can try there's no
harm in doing it tactfully it usually
won't work what I did in 2007 and there
were blog roles at the time to remember
those is I tried to figure out and you
can ask people right up front moderators
are good people to ask as well who do
these people view as a thought leader
okay so you have this group of 10
traffic leaders who do they read who are
the niche folks that they read who are
very influential who are the thought
leaders
and then you approach the thought
leaders invite them out to drink and you
do the same thing that I just described
and be very very candid basically do
like the Puss in Boots you know holding
the Hat with the big eyes and and it's
amazing what miracles can come of that
because if you get covered by one of
those thought leaders in an interview
for instance or anything like that or
you send them an exclusive excerpt even
though they have a small site you send
them an exclusive excerpt of the book
what happens they put it up and you're
like who cares 20,000 readers but guess
who those 20,000 readers are okay it's
like being in front of 20,000 TED
attendees okay so don't be a traffic
bigot and I would also say that don't
necessarily focus on the people who you
perceive as the a-listers or VIPs now
try to find the previews does that make
sense you're trying to find the
up-and-comers so you ask again ask
people who have been here a few times
who are the best like up-and-coming hot
designers you know the folks that are
not very well known who should be
well-known or who are the the hot lock
the hot up-and-coming filmmakers who
haven't had any press who are they go
meet those people and by the way if you
did that just in safe film but your ass
actually based in tech you did that in
film you met the best up-and-comers the
best up-and-comers know one another the
best VIP is an a-listers know one
another it's not industry specific okay
so don't be a traffic bigot it'll also
have a much better time while you're
here
questions for a listers so if you're
like yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
Ferris you know I'm still I'm still
gonna go for the gold I'm gonna sprint
up to you know Al Gore and give him the
pitch well how should you do it what are
the questions what are the ice breakers
for the a-listers and the first rule as
far as I'm concerned is ask if they have
a second don't just run up and pitch
because a great pitch the perfect pitch
at a bad time is a bad pitch it won't
work
and like I said at the beginning it's
not about making a good impression it's
about not making a bad impression if you
make a bad impression they won't want to
communicate with you later even if you
correct things okay so mr. MS X may I
bother you for 30
mr. MS X is now an okay time for one
question if you say that
don't ask three questions one question
now number two and number three here
actually worked very well together
you know mr. mrs. X it's now an okay
time for one question who on your team
could I email about whatever you're
interested in okay they're not going to
give you their personal email they're
not going to give you their personal
phone number usually and it's going to
make them very uncomfortable to say no
so realize that and ask about their team
that will immediately put you in the pro
category as opposed to the amateur
category and another thing if you're in
a group let's just say at a book signing
or something like that you have to
realize even if they wanted to give you
their personal email phone they can't
say it out loud because ten other people
are going to hear it so who on your team
could it email about blah and if they
have entourage around them meaning let's
just say you go to a book signing for
fill in the blank right Michael Pollan
and you see someone who's just kind of
patiently waiting they're ten feet away
that is probably his publicist or his
publisher or someone along those lines
get to know them they are probably the
gateway to communication with mr. Pollan
so you don't have to pitch directly and
this relates to everything I've just
said I'm not gonna spend a ton of time
on it but you have to prove the
messenger before the message you were
the messenger so for instance I had a
startup come up to me while I was headed
to this room today and I'm not going to
mention their company name but they came
up and the first thing they said was hey
your assistant hasn't replied to my
emails so what do you expect me to
respond with how do you want me to
respond to that like get a lot of emails
I don't know you know my assistants
pretty good a shitty email I don't know
and then his buddy with them is like
yeah mr. four hours like give me some
for our equip and I'm like if and then
he gave me his business card and I'm
like all right if I go to your site
let's just say it's the most amazing
sight I've ever seen in my life
am I gonna want to be associated with
that so that he can go up to somebody
else and be a mr. Poli
mr. fierce rich with us and there's like
no hell no that would destroy my
reputation
so you just screwed the pooch all right
so be a good messenger before you
deliver the message doesn't matter how
good the pitches if you [ __ ] it up first
f-bombs are coming how to pick people
out of a crowd these are all really the
questions that I get repeatedly how do
you pick someone out of a crowd you're
scanning the room you want to work the
room everyone don't work the room number
two if you had to pick people out of the
crowd I would say go for the most
relaxed unrushed looking person not
necessarily the a-listers surrounded by
a huge balance of people that's the
right word because unless you just want
to listen if you want to listen that's
fine but you're not gonna get a lot of
airtime look for the most relaxed people
in the room there either have very very
little going on or they've kind of
already made it and they don't feel
rushed
so hit or miss but if you have to pick
people out of the crowd I would say go
for the most relaxed unrushed looking
person all right icebreakers in general
and as a preface to this and I know
you're reading the slide while I talk
that's okay this small talk is the big
talk
all right I'll repeat that the small
talk is the big talk what that means is
and and that is an expression that has
been said to me in many different words
you know small talk is everything by
friends of mine like Ito Lafleur who's a
co-founder of yes to carrots that are
distributed in more than 30,000
locations and the point that he would
make and the point that I would also
make is that if you're just going to
pitch people you can probably do that in
a more effective way by staying at home
not coming to Austin and just sending
out cold pitches working on your email
skill here in person you have an
opportunity to dig deeper and talk about
other things that is how you become
memorable that is how you have that one
deep human connection that I was talking
about so instead of asking what do you
do and there are people who will ask
that of you and you could be like oh
shoot a lot of heroin what about you
know that's a good way to end it
or you can give it a really boring
answer like sometimes I'll be like yeah
I'm a free
writer you know still trying to make it
work and they're like Oh already
scanning for their next prey so instead
of what do you do what do you ask and I
understand why this is difficult because
people are like I don't know and then
they come up with something like if you
could be a breakfast cereal what
breakfast sir would you be and people
are like what that's kind of what the
hell's happening so don't do that
you can make it pretty natural so for
instance if you ask Oh so-and-so hey
nice to meet you where you from and they
say uh from New York City are you from
New York City originally say no I'm from
Cincinnati well how do you get from head
you end up going from Cincinnati in New
York City you're gonna get all the
information you could possibly need for
context okay boom you've got it and
you'll oftentimes have a very good
personal story to go with it all right
now if you don't want to do that or
later on if you want to sort of expand a
little bit you could ask you know what
session are you most excited about
what's been your favorite session so far
if it's a few days from now for instance
you know what are you most excited about
these days it's not that you can't talk
about work
but you can do that anywhere via any
medium in-person is a unique opportunity
so optimized for meet space take
advantage of the fact you probably have
some booze involved and you have a
chance to talk about the personal stuff
how do you escape / pause conversations
so you know what do you do if you get
cornered by someone selling timeshares
or what do you do if if someone is just
on meth and will not stop talking about
their startup and they're just going and
going and going what do you do well I
would say a few things and I put a scape
slash pause because I think pause is the
better way to think about it you could
try to pull the bathroom manoeuvre
people always try this and it can work
you be like you know that's awesome so
fascinating I really have to go the
bathroom I'll be right back the dangers
of doing that number one if you don't
come back you kind of look like a dick
so violates that don't be a dick roll if
you don't even go to the bathroom if
you're like yes I need to go to the
bathroom then you just walk 20 feet and
then just start talking to someone
they're gonna be like picture at
so-and-so what a dick so don't do that
the easiest way to do it you don't have
to make up so oh my god my house is on
fire my wife is going I have to go you
don't
do that you can just say and this is
what I do and I do this with people I
find very very interesting also if it's
just like okay we've been talking for an
hour in your head you're thinking this I
just want to wander around a little bit
say that so you ask them hey you know
James or whatever you know hey James
you're gonna be here for the rest of the
for the rest of South but you're gonna
be here for a couple of days yeah I'm
gonna be here for the next two days cool
well Jeep a cart or something I'd love
to connect but I just want to wander
around maybe take a little breather grab
a cup of coffee
you're done that's great it's polite
it's honest that's all you have to do
are you gonna be here for the rest of
South by are you gonna be here for the
next couple of days cool can I get your
card great s want to wander around take
a break hit the bathroom grab a cup of
coffee but I'm sure I'll see you around
nobody's offended and you accomplished
the purpose of pausing the conversation
next follow-up
all right so during the event after the
event how do you follow up first of all
don't do anything to keep in touch it
will just make enemies alright you don't
need to ping busy people just be like
hey how's it going hey do you know I
imagine that you are calling them at
like 3 p.m.
alright so you call them they're like
it's an investment banker running around
oh my god your startup you're like we
need an underwriter so you call this
busy investment banker 3 p.m. okay
John it's uh it's Tim from South by it's
like uh Tim Tim Ferriss hey done let's
go on today don't do that so follow up
is a dish best served cold what I mean
by this is most people are gonna walk
out of South by pockets full of business
cards big ideas people to follow up with
people to ping brains to pick don't ever
ask anybody if you can pick their brain
over coffee by the way but that's a
separate story so follow up wait two
weeks ok wait two weeks why two weeks
because if you do it now it's gonna get
lost in the avalanche of similar stuff
if you do it right after South by it'll
be even worse you're gonna get lost in
another hundred follow up email so it
takes people time to catch up from
neglecting other things during South by
wait two weeks and then in terms of time
I would do it on
a Wednesday afternoon their time or a
Friday afternoon their time Sunday night
also works pretty well so for responses
for max response rate and read rate
those tend to be the times that I find
most effective play the long game play
the long game all this means is you
don't have to rush
why because you just have to have one
deep human connection with one person
that's it if you can accomplish that and
develop a long term relationship
you can potentially never have to
network again I know that sounds like an
exaggeration but if you look back at the
people I spent the most time with in
2007 realistically you'd probably be
able to have a couple of these human
interactions try to get out of tech by
the way don't do Alltech if you look at
the people I spent the most time with in
2007 about 90% of them this is 2007 what
is that seven years ago my god there's
still some of my closest friends to this
day that is what you want because if you
don't do that you play the short game
you have to then do this very time
consuming very energy consuming very
likely to offend a transactional stuff
every year for the rest of your life do
you really want to do that no no you
don't so play the long game guys that is
it for my formal presentation so I am
going to open it up to the rest of
Twitter Q&A but I hope you all have a
wonderful wonderful experience in South
by Southwest if you do it right it will
change your life so again just in
summary don't dismiss people don't be
dick and toll rush play the long game
thank you
cool thanks so much Tim so if you guys
have specific questions that you want to
ask if you want to hashtag your tweet
with ask Tim we will pull them up and he
will answer all of your lovely questions
concerns ponderings I and here is our
first question I really should have one
of my glasses for this I can read it
alright so this is from Wendy Perry can
you guys read this as well maybe I don't
have to read all these but I will just
for those who are getting this on audio
after I read the 4-hour work who years
ago I took my family on a mini break
once a month can you have too many this
is this is in reference to mini
retirements and taking these sabbaticals
so distributing retirement throughout
life as opposed to waiting until say
fifty sixty seventy two to load it up at
that point uh I think that this is a
deeply personal question so in terms of
mini retirements I try to take one to
three months usually two to three months
of these many sabbaticals per year I
think that if you use these mini
retirements as a way of postponing other
important decisions and of course it
could be too many so that if you look at
your to-do list
and usually the most uncomfortable item
is the most important if you're using
these trips to avoid that then I'd say
it's too many all right next is from
Zachary Barker if you were launching a
new company with only a thousand dollars
to get started what would you start so
we can I get a lot of questions like
this so it's like if you had no
connections and no money how would you
make a hundred thousand dollars in the
next quarter and what business would you
start uh this is a question of what I
would say I'd spend the first ten
dollars getting the 22 immutable laws of
marketing and now to figure out which
market you're going after first and then
design your product and specifically I
would also read 1,000 true fans by Kevin
Kelly and identify who your what the
demographic and psychographic is of the
thousand people you want to have as
diehard fans
first and foremost non celebrities in my
case with the 4-hour workweek
I knew that my first market not my
entire market but my first market would
be 25 to 40 year old tech savvy males
and near
City and San Francisco how do I reach
these people how can I seem say
ubiquitous by being on five web sites
when in fact I'm not ubiquitous I'm just
everywhere that they happen to look okay
that's where I would start but I can't
say you know put all your money in
Bitcoin or something like that which I
think would be dangerous especially if
you only have a thousand bucks so test
often test small I think Facebook is a
great place to thin slice but that would
be my advice do you meditate or do yoga
I do meditate I meditate almost every
morning for ideally 20 minutes it's only
something that I've done consistently
for the last year or so oh all right
and I personally use TM Transcendental
Meditation I find some of the guru stuff
a little woowoo I'm not for that but
just the repetition of a sound I find
very very effective as opposed to say
concentrative meditation or other types
if the pasta also very very helpful I am
not I don't do a lot of yoga I've become
fascinated with acro yoga which is more
like a Cirque de Soleil of strength
performance than anything else but those
are the two I meditate a lot more than I
do yoga
Anthony Blattner how do you find the
good events and parties instead of the
overpacked
events good events and parties all right
so I plan my sessions although there's
room to improvise
I let the parties pick me what that
means is I choose the sessions I
interact with people in the way that I
described and then you just ask okay try
to have some spontaneity and just wander
around and get lost in terms of events
if we're talking about conferences in
general this is gonna sound haphazard
but my policy has generally been go to
at least one event per year which is the
most expensive event you can afford to
go to you're going to end up with a
smaller crowd and I find that at least
interesting to experiment with but
obviously you don't to bet the farm on
it
next question from littlest Gator and I
like that name if you ever heard a
little baby alligators they go where
where when they're calling their mother
it's amazing I really want this guy to
make that noise
that you're a big deal what are your
goals at South by Southwest don't think
I'm big deal compared to a lot of folks
but my goals to South by Southwest
honestly I the I was offered the
opportunity to do how to rock South by
Southwest and I feel a huge debt of
gratitude to South by I think it's one
of the most incredible events out there
and if you do it right it could be
totally life-changing so I don't have I
don't have a new book I don't have a new
thing to promote if this time around
it's really just to have fun eat some
barbecue and hopefully allow you guys to
do the same next mark Marshall or
Michelle what thought leaders do you
follow or are there specific writers
bloggers that I read right now at this
point in time there's some very
interesting folks out there I mean
Nassim Taleb is one that comes to mind
immediately but in terms of reading I'm
trying to actually read really old ideas
right now so I'm trying to focus on
books that have been around for a
hundred plus years whenever possible
because in a in an age of ephemeral and
did a neo mania and Votan
obsession with the new the new the new I
like ideas that have stood the test of
time for a while how do I stay focused
not convinced I am focused but
meditation helps a lot and really the
purpose of that session in the morning I
might just be thinking of like some guy
who cut me off in the salad line and
college that I want to like punch in the
nose for 19 minutes of that but if I'm
thinking of that and I'm like not
productive and then I go back to what
I'm supposed to be doing just once that
will translate to being able to do the
same thing in your normal life so I
think that's very very helpful in terms
of books on meditation the first book by
tick not hon is very very good alright
melody towel how do you deal with
criticism you get for not replying to
email right away you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna head I'm gonna dodge this one
just because I answered it at length in
the 4-hour workweek so I apologize guys
but that's a long long answer so that
that one that we're gonna save for the
4-hour work I'm sure it's on torrent
somewhere if somebody wants to read it
for free
or her but Morial question what part of
your 4-hour workweek do you personally
find hardest to follow what I found
hardest and what I still find hardest is
saying no you have to say no to thousand
things before you can say yes to the one
big thing that's going to change your
life and I still find that difficult I
think we all like people to like us and
some people take it very personally when
you don't get back to get back to them
quickly like the startup founder kind of
a costed me outside it's like and I feel
badly but at the same time I'm just like
try to walk a mile in my shoes if you
could just think about it because I used
to take it personally to I'd send an
email to a really busy person they would
never responded back wow what a dick you
have to try to imagine yourself in their
shoes and the reality is they're getting
thousands of email thousands of pitches
probably 90% of the interactions I have
it South by Southwest will be people
pitching me so just imagine how that
would feel and how tiring it would be
before taking it personally but I still
find saying no quite challenging
Ryan bond heart how do I want people to
remember me I would say I don't need
people to remember me if they remember
the ideas that would be fantastic
most of which I've borrowed from other
people are just collected but I would
say that my goal is to be a world-class
teacher and to create people who are
better than I am so if I can create
armies thousands tens of thousands
millions of people who are world class
learners and in turn can be world class
teachers then and better than I am which
is necessary then I think the world be a
better place so hopefully that's
something I can do
John adlai what tricks do you have for
retaining info if it's factual
declarative information facts and
figures there's a book written by a
gentleman named Higby I think it's
called your memory and how to improve it
but the last name is a Higby mnemonic
devices as used by cicero and for
several thousand years work really well
Edie cook co ke also fascinating guy
world-class memory competitor I
interviewed on the podcast
what's the next project book that I'm
working on
well more details to come shortly but
well okay I'll give you guys some some
breaking news no one knows this I was
able to negotiate back the rights for TV
show that I filmed some time ago
and I will be digitally distributing the
Tim Ferriss experiment to the well I
would like to say the world there are
some constraints geographically but I
will be distributing it and making it
available to as many people as humanly
possible in the next few months
so that's that's very exciting for me
hopefully I can come back to South by
next year and do something in the film
track and talk about these new avenues
for distribution which I think are
really exciting homeless coder that's a
good guy I saw a guy two days ago in San
Francisco he was like slow motion karate
chopping this tree into my mind I was
like either that guy's high as balls on
LSD or he's coming up with the next
billion-dollar idea he's a coder it's
gotta be one of the two homeless coder
you've advocated mini retirements and
travel where is the best place in the
world besides Austin I you know it this
is like what's the best pair of shoes in
the world you have to find the pair that
fits and it's not the same for everybody
some people like those crazy like pointy
Witch of the West shoes I've seen a lot
of guys in those not my thing you know
flip-flop guy I love Japan
uh-huh I have a huge affinity for Japan
if I lived there for a year in high
school that's that's the Argentine is a
lot of fun too it's amazing how they can
get anything done just beautiful
hilarious people great wine great steak
Japan is amazing because it is a place
where you can be completely confused and
illiterate and lost and not be in danger
so if you want to be a really really
uncomfortable but not really in any
particular danger Japan is a great place
to do it
Melanie Curtin what are you most excited
about for this year's South by I'm most
excited about eating a lot of animals
I don't I don't have a real agenda while
I'm here there are there a number of
friends of mine who have moved to Austin
because it is the best place in the
world and I'd like to just reconnect
with some of my friends many of whom I
met into that actually two of them I'm
meeting in the next three days I met for
the first time at South by 2007 and
they've continued to be to my best
friends so that's about it
this is from be cursed 77 on your
podcast with Matt Mullenweg you guys
spoke briefly about poly synchronous
sleep have you tried it does it work
so poly synchronous I've never heard of
phrase that way most people have heard
if they have heard it polyphasic sleep
where you take instead of a single hour
or I'm sorry a single block of eight
hours you can break it down into
fractions where you can get down to two
two and a half hours of sleep if you do
it take a 20-minute nap every few hours
I have tried it and it can work and I
still am a I'm a huge believer in naps
huge huge believer in naps despite the
fact that I have a lot of trouble with
them pro tip for naps that I've realized
it's not about falling - it's not about
falling asleep it's about laying down
and closing your eyes and just blocking
out some sensory input so don't get
stressed out if you can't fall asleep
for 20 minutes just lay down chill out
I've tried it it works it's massively
antisocial you can have no social
calendar whatsoever so I don't typically
follow it Luigi linguae tell what's the
most memorable thank-you note that I've
received oh that's a good question I've
been very fortunate I've had a good a
good tear over the last couple years and
there's there's a lot component there's
time in component you know hopefully
there's some kind of this competency
component but you know the first one
that's coming to mind I've received a
lot of really lovely thank-you letters
but the first one that comes to mind has
nothing to do with the 4-hour workweek
it's actually a collection of thank-you
notes from I think there were third
graders or fourth graders from doing
work with donorschoose.org which is an
educational nonprofit I really love and
spend a lot of time with them on their
advisory board and I got this collection
of thank-you notes for supplying some
basic materials like
books or pens or pencils so that's the
first one that comes to mind is just
these these hand you know crack a lot of
I'm not a parent yet so I don't have the
you know the like poorly drawn
brontosaurus to stick on my refrigerator
and I got you know thirty hand-drawn
letters from these kids which was just
awesome i GD ml are you recording a
podcast while here at South by if yes
with whom I don't have any plans to
record here at South by I might know if
I might do a man on the street walk
around see how many drunk people I can
get to say incriminating things I don't
know but no no plans right now what
animal best describes you Edwin Lee also
a good question this is a good one
Alexis Ohanian of Y Combinator likes to
ask people in job interviews what is
your spirit animal which I think gets a
pretty good answer or causes some
awkwardness of the release a coyote I'd
say I'd say prankster Joker stuff we go
into that for a while but others leave
it I think coyote is pretty good one
Jackie Bloom I have a 9 to 5 job can
4-hour workweek actually transformed my
life I'm not in a position to leave my
regular job I would say yes and the
reason I say that is that the 4-hour
workweek is really a portfolio of tools
for maximizing your per hour output so
there is somebody actually just on
Twitter a couple of days ago if you look
at my favorites if you look at my
favorites on Twitter at T Ferriss you
can see tons and tons of real life case
studies from the 4-hour workweek and
4-hour body and one of them was you know
took me five months to negotiate it but
I now have a room up a remote work
agreement so he's in his current job
same job getting paid the same amount it
has complete freedom of mobility that's
a big deal and because that that helps
to reward performance over presence and
it leads to great things so it's it's
not about getting to a 4-hour workweek
for everyone it's about maximizing your
per hour output and then making better
decisions with more options Andrew Berg
what are the 3 to 4 best bodyweight
exercises for business travelers
well I would say you can keep it really
simple push-ups planks if you want to
make planks harder you can put the soles
of your feet against the wall so your
feet are off the ground and you have to
press back into the wall to make it work
that's quite challenging and pull-ups if
you have access to pull-ups I would say
that if you do just that pistils if you
can handle it but pistols are hard for a
lot of people there's one legged squats
otherwise just two tips if you train
your abs in your grip you can keep your
entire body in really good shape abs we
are talking about planks listen to my
podcast with Pavel Toulon for more
details on that get some hand grippers
as a as a dude I'm not sure as all the
ladies here want like thick calloused
meat hooks but grippers rippers are
incredible to travel with and you can
also if you're really aggressive and
want to go for it you can get a kayaking
dry bag that people use to put their
wallets and so on iPhones inside to keep
dry while it turns out you can use a dry
back to contain water also so you can
roll up a dry bag travel with it fill it
up with water say in the bathtub and get
it up to like 3040 pounds so you can
just use that as a kettlebell or as a
dumbbell so you can you can get around
the space constraints Jessi Conover
what's the best way to respond to do you
have a business card when I don't have
one no I I just say I'm sorry I'm really
unprofessional I don't have business
cards that's it I think that does that
does the job and then usually I say I'm
sorry I don't need business cards but
you know I'll shoot my info if you mean
it if not then don't say that all right
next question
Erik qual Minh what do most
entrepreneurs do wrong what do most
entrepreneurs do wrong I think they try
to do what most most entrepreneurs
invest too much in their business before
they test product market fit
so dude I mentioned before read the 22
immutable laws of marketing read a
thousand true fans by Kevin Kelly which
is free
and figure out exactly who your ideal
customer is and who those thousand
people are where they're located what
they read where they'd be on Facebook
which pages they've probably liked and
test your landing page use something
like Unbounce or leadpages or something
to test the offer before you invest in a
ton of inventory or a ton of software
development and I think that's that's
the right way to approach it along the
same lines is Luigi at Dell what's the
most memorable memento I've received ah
boy again it's just the first one that
comes to mind I was in Japan at one
point filming a TV show where I was
attempting to learn Japanese horseback
archery in a week really dangerous turns
out I don't recommend it you can you can
find it online if you learn if you just
search Japanese horseback archery in my
name of all the things and the teacher
there gave me an a an out-of-print tiny
book on Yabusame which it's called in
Japanese that he was featured in with an
inscription from the foremost family who
used to work with the Shogunate teaching
Yabusame and the the sort of prodigy
right now who's incredible rider
incredible Archer has a jacket he didn't
give me the jacket I would've loved the
jacket but it said Olga saw out a job
with that man since 11 57 or something
like that since 11 something I was like
that it's amazing I want that jacket I
didn't get the jacket I got the book but
that was enough all right
advice for introverts advice for
introverts is take time timeouts so I I
can play the extrovert but I get
exhausted at events I get exhausted and
crowds I get exhausted at book signings
I get really really drained i recharge
my batteries by myself so if you need to
take a break go outside chill out for 10
minutes lean against the wall like lay
it out on the park take time to recharge
if you try to play the extrovert for too
long you'll just get burned out and then
the next day you won't even participate
so drink a lot of water
and recharge josh Jansen what are some
of the biggest lessons you've learned
from starting my podcast the podcast
started as a lark it was really a
commitment to do six episodes because I
wanted to get better at conversation and
asking questions my favorite part of
writing books is not actually the
writing it's the research and it's
interviewing world-class experts and
trying to deconstruct what they do and I
viewed the podcast as a way of
practicing that and getting much better
at it and I've had some wonderful
experiences being interviewed on say Joe
Rogan's podcast or Marc Maron and I
wanted to see if I enjoyed being the
host so I would say first and foremost
what I've learned is that it's not
enough to have the right question to
have the right answer so you need to
have the right questions so you can get
you can get a great answer to the wrong
question and it ends up meaning very
little but if you have if you have a
portfolio of really good questions man
you can do just about anything and
that's number one number two is ask
simple follow-on questions so someone
says well I did this I did this at this
why did you choose to do that what did
you learn from that you know what do you
learn from that that you haven't talked
about before these these follow-up
questions are often where the jams
really come out all right next question
Gabby did Leon what are some tips for
executing on all the great ideas
gathered at ia Iowa Oh Interactive was
I'm not sure once we return home I'm
guessing that is from the conference I
you don't want to execute on all the
great ideas it's way way way too much so
I would look at your ideas the potential
collaborations and all that and ask
yourself which one of these if if
executed will make all of the others
irrelevant or easier and then focus on
that one so find the lead Domino and
focus on that when I think we'll take
one more question and then direct
everyone to the signing sure
next one is Jindra ch4 borsky let's do
it let's do one more question after this
because I don't think I have a good
answer for this is there any particular
session that's out by that you want to
attend at least one I wasn't able to get
my badge yet so I haven't had a chance
to get the book with the sessions let's
do one more
mmm this is a good one
Alex Wyckoff what questions do you use
for reflection and why so reflection
meditation I view those is the same
thing I will journal in the mornings
quite often and whenever I'd say every
four to eight weeks at longest I will
wake up in the morning and I will do an
8020 inventory of my emotional states so
what does that mean that means that I'll
sit down before checking email doing any
of that check my phone and I will ask
the question you know what are 20% of
the activities and relationships that
are producing 80% of my positive
emotional states and then what are the
20% of activities and people who are
creating 80% of the negative emotional
states the overwhelm the guilt and so on
and put together a to-do list and a not
to do list accordingly specifically than
not to do list the things to cut out so
those are that is the set of questions
and I find most valuable good question
and good answer well cool thanks the
enta man thanks everyone here for
joining us everybody have a great shout
bye
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed it and until
next time thank you for listening